[Music]
jared leto doesn't seem to be too
excited about the new Joker movie after
its controversial but very elaborate
Joker performance from 2016 which
brought him a lot of praise and
criticism the path for him seems to go
neither in the direction of a solo
spin-off nor in the direction of a joker
and Harlequin movies instead Warner
Brothers shows a completely different
character The Joker played by Joaquin
Phoenix was absolutely no connection to
the DC Universe according to The
Hollywood Reporter Jared Leto is said to
have been pretty upset about that and to
have felt passed over no wonder since
Harlequin gets her own solo movie with
birds of prey Joaquin Phoenix has a lot
more Hollywood experience and in the
Suicide Squad too there is no room for
letter because of a fight with director
James Caan the new Joker film has been
shown in cinema since October for
Halloween is getting closer and closer
and so is the time of horror movie
releases of course the Halloween figure
should not be missing Michael Myers
he made an incredible comeback last year
in David Gordon Green's film now the
movie Halloween kills is supposed to tie
directly to the celebrated first
Halloween part of John Carpenter from
1978 and ignore all other sequels even
the old actors from the first part are
now engaged again for example Charles
ciphers the now 80 year old already
impersonated sheriff Leigh Brackett in
the first two parts of Halloween and
will now be seen as the same in front of
the camera again also pagan the roles
will be Carl Richards as Lindsey Wallace
Nick Castle as Michael Myers and Nancy
Stephens as sister Marion Michael Mayer
sister Laurie Strode who already made
his life much harder in the 2018 remake
should not be missing either a
well-known location from the second part
has already been leaked which is the
heaven filled Memorial Hospital to what
extent the Halloween 2 location will be
filled with similar scenes and murders
can only be speculated Halloween kills
will be released on October 16 2020 its
successor Halloween ends will be
released one year later on October 16
2021
our Marvel movies real cinema the
director legend Martin Scorsese answered
this question with the clear note
according to the wolf of wallstreet
producer they are something like theme
parks he literally said in an interview
with Empire
magazine it isn't the cinema of human
beings trying to convey emotional
psychological experiences to another
human being
shortly afterwards MCU I can rub it down
in jr. himself replied in a conversation
with radio presenter Howard Sturm that
he didn't feel attacked by it at all in
addition he says that they need all the
different perspectives so that they can
find the right to the middle and ads at
the end that the MCU films are
definitely cinema for him
samuel l.jackson who is better known as
Nick Fury in the MCU also expressed his
opinion he told a variety I mean that's
like saying Bugs Bunny ain't fun terms
are films everybody doesn't like his
stuff either everybody's got an opinion
so I mean it's okay ain't going to stop
nobody from making movies last but not
least we would like to share with you
the opinion of James Gunn who as a
successful director is the one who can
understand Scorsese's words the best on
Twitter estates Martin Scorsese is one
of my five favorite living filmmakers I
was outraged when people picketed The
Last Temptation of Christ without having
seen the film I'm saddened that he's now
judging my films in the same way at the
end of the day this discussion won't
change anything anyway as on the one
hand the Marvel movies for the next
years are already announced on the other
hand Scorsese can prove to everyone with
his upcoming Netflix the extra epic the
Irishman that he himself is making real
cinema the next years are not only
filled with Marvel movies but also some
Marvel series will celebrate their
release in the next year's for example
the Falcon and the Winter Soldier or ran
the vision another Marvel series which
has no direct connection to the MCU will
be released next year namely the very
dark serious health room which revolves
around the offspring of a serial killer
much more about the story isn't really
known yet but some actors are the main
roles are the siblings Damon and Anna
hellström who are played by Tom Austin
known from the Royals and Sidney Lemmon
from fear The Walking Dead both of the
characters live kind of double life
while damon lectures as a professor
during the day and anna runs an auction
house both of them go on a diamond hunt
at night
in the cartoon both are children of the
devil her mother had to be admitted to a
psychiatric ward when she found out who
her husband really was regarding the
comics house from his part of the house
from storyline as part of the Ghost
Rider comics the series is to be
produced for Hugh Liu the release year
is set for 2020
John wick is currently one of the most
successful action films ever only this
year with its third path 323 million
u.s. dollars were brought in which in
total is more than both predecessors
together the fact that the successor
John wick four will happen was already
known when the third part was released
but now there are news about the
spin-off ballerina that was announced in
2017 as deadline reports a director
respond for it namely underworld anti
hat 4.0 director Len Wiseman in terms of
content ballerina is about a young hit
woman who wants to take revenge on the
murderers of her family she said to have
completed her education at the school
which is led in the third part by a
woman who has only known as the director
unfortunately it is not yet known who is
considered for the leading role and
rather Keanu Reeves could also play a
role as well it seems likely that
ballerina will be released between pod
three and four so the most likely
release is in 2020
[Music]